so this is going to be about a quality
problem in communication complexity you
might think there's nothing left to say
about it but they're still things one
can investigate and this is stone work
with my student right audition with
DiMaggio Vince key so the model
everybody knows how introduced
communication complexity in 1979 and in
the same paper you also introduced the
simultaneous message passing model and
that model works like this so we have
Alice and Bob but we also have a referee
Ellis has an input X bob has wife and
the referee he does not have an input
but he is supposed to learn the output
of the function and the motivation ok I
guess this is maybe the simplest
communication model you can investigate
over the one with the highest lower
bounds actually there is another
motivation that essentially you can use
this to give lower bounds for data
streaming algorithms that work by a
linear sketching and that is actually
there's a resulted in some sense you can
assume without loss of generality that
you're using linear sketches although
this box for the public Cohen version of
this model and importantly so this is a
communication model where there's an
actual difference between public and
private coin randomness which we don't
usually have so variations of this can
be deterministic randomized or quantum
and we can use this notation
deterministic SMP complexity randomized
quantum and we will only consider
private coin protocols here and the
deterministic model is actually not
interesting it's exactly the sum of the
two one-way complexities so we don't
really need to consider this model but
relation like this is not true for
randomized complexity as observed by
BIOS avatar now maybe the problem to
study in this model is equality and
everybody knows this problem I guess so
LS nas ex both more spine we want to
know whether X is equal or why but we
are going to look at two different
flavors of this equality and non
equality because we're going to look at
a non-deterministic version of this
model okay so note that the public coin
protocols are not interesting here so if
you have a public coin then you can use
fingerprinting and have other one
complexity protocol for these problems
so we're looking at the private court
version and there's a very nice result
to the boom Annette are from for 15
years ago maybe that shows that if you
have a quantum messages then you can
solve equality with log n bits of
communication so L it sends a quantum
fingerprint Bob sends a quantum
fingerprint and then they can do the
swab test to check whether these
fingerprints are the same ok so there's
a long line of previous results on this
and let me tell you about this so yahoo
asked the question in 79 and in what is
the complexity of equality in the
simultaneous message passing model and
it took an amazing 17 years before this
was resolved so a minus or show the
lower bound of square root and actually
criminy's on one conjectured in 95 that
it's going to be omega n but it turned
out to be square root n and in the same
year Newman integrity showed a matching
lower bound and if you look at this
paper is really a technical tour de
force it's I mean it goes like this you
try to show that you want to approximate
in the Infinity norm the identity matrix
by a product of three non-negative
matrices a and B and a is 2 to the M
times M M is M by M and B is M by 2 to
the end you want to show what is the
smallest em you can have and it looks
like it's a difficult question when and
this it's it's really tough the proof
a little time later Barbra in kemah gave
a much simpler proof based on the
randomization so they boost one of the
messages so that the error goes down and
then you can essentially replace it by a
deterministic message so this is a lot
simpler and began and Rick doesn't
essentially had the same idea also in
2001 chakrabarti at all in one of these
seminal information complexity papers
show the direct some result in the same
model and in 2008 kavinsky and auditory
give and runs the both looked at the
following thing you have one quantum
message and one classical message so
Alice's quantum Bobby's classically and
then you have a square root end with a
loss of a lot factor so it's a long
history and we're going to do two things
so I'll give you an even simpler proof
okay if you want to take only one thing
away from the talk then it will be that
proof and we study the situation where
there's another party Merlin who also
sends a message to the referee and this
guy is not trustworthy but he knows
possibly okay and we study all
non-trivial combinations of quantum
classical messages and give tight bonds
for everything so why do we do that
first of all we're interested in the
power of quantum proofs over classic
approves and there's going to be
something rather nice happening here and
secondly i think is natural to look at
the non-deterministic version of the
simultaneous message passing so and this
is the model okay so we have Alice she's
Xbox is why Merlin this guy cannot be
trusted but he sees both inputs they
sent to the referee referee produces the
output and you have the usual sounds and
completeness conditions okay I'm not
going to spare them out here so there
are few observations about this now we
can denote the type of protocol here
depending on what these messages are
quantum or classical okay bye things
like RQ RQ
Ellis Bob and murrelets message type and
we're going to use a B&M for the message
length and the things we know is if
alice and bob are quantum everything is
locked and no provers need it also if
you go into this photo combine this
actually the more interesting thing is
that trade-off so for every a and B such
that a B is M you have an hour protocol
with message links a and message links
be for Alice and Bob this is both an
upper and a lower bound ok and of course
there's another one called trivial
protocol maybe where Merlin just sends X
say hey let's say it's a quality problem
Merlin sense x and Alice and Bob just
sent a fingerprint of of x and y and if
these fingerprints coincide with the
fingerprint of that string then you can
decide that the things the Edison Papa
are also equal so in the following I
will give you a table of results we
assume that the product of message
length is too short ok Alice and Bob
cannot solve the problems by themselves
otherwise we don't need to consider the
existence of the proof of Merlin and
here is the table of origin if you
cannot be trusted we try to verify it
right it's a Merlin us again so he's a
pro he sent some message and hey if I
mean it has the usual soundness and
completeness side so if the function
value is 1 then there is a proof that he
can give that will be accepted with high
probability and if function value is 0
then no proof no matter what he does
will be acceptable
is it important that modeling does not
say anything to Allison both in your
model it's just a yes I think so
otherwise you can eat these things will
be trivial as 10 okay so there's a lot
of things we have for interesting models
we have equality and nany quality and
one thing I'd like to point out if you
only care about the maximum message
length it's all going to be square root
N and this points were not known before
of course but there's no difference here
whatsoever however if you look at the
trade-offs there's some subtleties
arising and one thing I'd like to point
out is that in the case of equality and
the classical proven XO the proper can
send a randomized or actually it's
deterministic message then if you Alice
and Bob don't have enough information
that they send a referee then the proof
has to be length in this is too no
matter of his quantum or randomized here
and on the other hand non equality is
easier ok so if you have a classical
proven non equality is easier than
equality that's not too surprising
because there should be a certificate
for saying these things are not equal
right however it turns out if you have a
quantum proven then equality in non
equality have exactly the same lower and
upper bounds ok here's some log factors
at least arise from two different
protocols but I mean you're not going to
be able to digest all the different
bounds here but the most interesting
effect is if you have a quantum proven
an equality and on equality are equally
hard your classic groover they're
different ok so the total communications
root and the trade-offs are different
and classical poova equality is harder
for equality no proof shorter than just
giving the whole string is useful at all
and even giving Alex a quantum message
doesn't help at all if there's a quantum
prove or than equality non equality are
really equally hard ok so could we
approve this with previous methods we
don't think so so there's one result
pertaining to this is due to Aronson who
shows how to do merly nice Merlin us are
one-way protocols and we can use this
together with the previous d
randomization or D quantization
technique and we get an N to the
one-third lower bound for this problem
which is the best we can squeeze out of
this because it contains two different
results okay and so in the case where we
don't have approval we can actually use
previous techniques to get a tight bond
but they don't seem to work for this
case where we have a proven okay so now
I'm going to prove just the straight
randomized lower bound and i'm going to
say later how to extend this using this
technique but you also see just how easy
it is so we consider the Equality
problem there are two players who send
random messages okay and these messages
okay we could this is maybe a step that
is somewhat unorthodox we consider a
given protocol okay so usually in
communication complexity you don't
consider the protocol you look at
properties of the communication matrix
are you sure there's no big and clean
rectangle or anything like that the only
other proof I know is the original carry
on azonda Ramage Nootka proof for this
joint is where you also take do
something to the protocol so we take the
protocol p and what is it actually this
is an encoding function of Ellis right
she encodes X using some private
randomness so let's denote this random
variable EI of X that is Alice's message
similar for Bob there's a message the
encoding of why I mean it's not an
encoding where you get the string back
right I just call it an encoding it just
has to be enough to check equality and
we assume that the message lengths are a
and B okay so that's the setup we take
the protocol inside the protocol there's
an encoding function and now we try to
find the distribution on the input they
will fool the protocol
so let's start with the uniform
distribution on strings x.x all strings
x.x of lengths and take the uniform
distribution that might not fool the
protocol right but now it's a randomized
encoding function gear so I could say a
of X and are but this is a random
variable so let's take 100 a samples of
Bob's message for a fixed input X to Bob
so you say it's a random variable so
that it will have different values but
they were 100 a of them and we look at
the information right and this is
actually very reminiscent of what
antioch did on monday so the information
between Alice's encoding of x given her
private randomness and those 100 a
different samples of Bob's encoding of X
under this under the uniform all right
is it most a just because this is only a
bit all right now we apply this idea of
killing correlation by conditioning all
right so what we get is by the chain
rule for some random I the information
between Alice's encoding of X and this
particular sample which is distributed
exactly the same way as before right
these are all the same guys up to the
randomness conditioned on this i minus 1
previous guys is at most 100 planets
stats and what what this means is that
after conditioning the messages or
changing the distribution so that it is
now conditioned on some value of these
guys we have that in the new
distribution and we get the information
between the two and coatings is small
one over 100 ok that means according to
the Pinsker inequality or what does it
actually
mean the information is small means it's
close to a product distribution right
Alice's message and Bob's message on the
same string is close to a product
distribution and that's not good okay so
furthermore if the lengths of these
skies individual is B and the lengths of
I mean there are 100 a and a times B
sufficiently smaller than n then this
distribution we get by conditioning here
still has life in it they're still
entropy unit actually we don't need a
lot if it's one bit is enough but you
can have Omega n entropy in this so and
which statement okay so we start with
the uniform distribution on pairs X X
now we look at the distribution that is
induced after I mean can view this as an
expectation over the different values
here and you can fix them and on average
it will have 1 over 100 information so
you take one value of these messages and
fix them and that puts a condition on
the distribution you get from it so you
achieve a new distribution where the
information is small but this mute new
different distribution that you it loses
some entropy right and the entropy that
it loses is at most the number on
average is at most a number of bits that
you fix you which is less than n so we
get a distribution on inputs that sits
on X X so that addresses encoding
function on this inputs looks very much
like a product distribution when X and X
are chosen from you and they use their
private randomness furthermore you still
has some entropy in it and if we look at
another distribution namely the product
of the marginals of MU then the
probability that X is not equal to Y
which choose X from you a and why from
you be
the probability that they are not equal
is very high all right we have a
distribution but we choose from the
marginals and there's entropy in there
so they are going to be different as
very high probability but that means mu
is on one inputs of equality and this
product distribution is mostly on zero
inputs of equality but they are under
this distribution these things are close
to product and the referee he
essentially needs to distinguish these
two cases otherwise they cannot solve
equality which means but we because
they're closed they're hard to tell
apart this means that the protocol must
have had error very close to one half
and that's it okay its really fairly
simple proof and one thing that comes
out immediately is that it does not
matter where the Ellises message is
quantum or not so let's go back and see
why that is all we need is that this
information inequality holds and we have
the chain rule it still holds if this
thing is quantum okay what happens if
Bob's is quantum now that would be very
bad because what we're doing here is
we're using this conditional entropy and
we want to say we can fix these guys and
you cannot fix the quantum state like
that and have this information chain
rule or this definition of conditional
quantum entropy so one of the guys can
be quantum the other one cannot which is
fine because if both messages are
quantum then this lower bound is just
not to so how do we get to the
non-deterministic case well there's the
one out of two problem which is the
variation of equality so Ellis gets two
strings X and X prime book gets y and
the promise is that X is equal to Y or X
prime is equal to Y and the referee has
to decide that okay in particular let's
say he has to accept if X prime is equal
to Y now using slightly more involved
version of this argument we were able to
show that even for this problem the
length of the
the product of the lengths of the
messages has to be Omega n okay and this
seems to be the bottleneck the previous
proofs that don't work for this problem
but I was generalized very easily okay
how does that work let me just give you
an example if we have now this case with
Merlin and Alice and Bob but let's take
the strongest one alice is quantum
wellness quantum and or poor bob is
random and we look at non equality which
is should be the easier of the two
problems so again we take any qrq
problem p and we give a reduction from
the two out of one problem okay so I'm
going to abuse this protocol this
protocol just couldn't consists of Ellis
having any message Bob sending a message
and they said an honest Merlin the
honest Merlin is able to convince in the
case their strings are really not equal
so we changed it so that Ellis has an
additional input set because we want to
use the protocol to a gift of the two
other one and you can think of this that
Merlin now actually talks to Ellis and
if X is not equal to Y he gives her y +
else he gives her a random set but maybe
that's all so confusing just think that
she gets an additional input and what
she does is she sends her a message to
the referee but she also simulates the
honest Merlin on her additional input
and her original input so Ellis just
takes over the role of Merlin and Bob he
just sent his message and what we get is
a QR protocol there's no longer approval
for the one out of two problem namely if
X happens to be not equal to Y so we
really have that y is equal to this
additional input then L assimilates the
honest Merlin and the referee will be
convinced if on the other hand ax is
equal to Y and that is not equal to X
then due to the conditions of the marina
the protocol no proof will convince the
referee
no matter what else would send them she
will always simulate the honest Merlin
for this string set okay this I think
can be a little bit confusing but this
gives a way to abuse the a protocol for
with else bob and merlin which is qrq to
give a QR protocol for the two out of
one problem and we have the lower bound
for the two out of one problem and this
implies that the sum of a plus M times B
so this is the length of the new
protocol of Alice's message and this is
boss message has to be larger than n
that means if a B is little over and
then M must have been large and we also
have a protocol that matches that ok let
me see a little bit about the upper
bound in the quantum case so there's
something interesting happening there we
want to D quantize this quantum finger
protocol and what we use is a new
primitive in quantum information I don't
know how interesting it is but it's just
exactly what we need and we call it
untranslated quantum state transfer so
here we have Ellis and Merlin and they
know a classical description of a
quantum state Phi pure quantum state
it's just the n-dimensional let's say a
real vector or complex if you on this so
it's a state on log and cubits and we
have now the trusted player and the
untrusted player and the referee needs
to get an approximate copy of this
quantum state just really as a quantum
state not the classical description that
will be impossible to do anything
non-trivial now that the catch is that L
is she's honest and she knows the
quantum state but she can only send
classical information on the other hand
Merlin the dishonest guy he can send
quantum information ok and the task is
for the referee to learn this copy so
why is this useful well we have this
quantum fingerprinting protocol in which
Alice and Bob Center posting to the
referee we want to take the Merlin who
can get the fingerprint and Alice to
cooperate to give the referee still
p of the quantum state and I give you
almost done here so okay Allison referee
so I'm showing this under the assumption
that Ellison there are four you share a
public coin Ellis and Merlin oil listen
Bob they'd never share a public coin but
Ellis and the referee we assume here for
simplicity they share a public coin this
can be removed with the new man
technique in communication complexity
source fairly straightforward so they
agree on the random soft base of R to
the N of dimension a a is a parameter
will be square root in our application
well Ellison's is a approximate
classical description of the projection
of this quantum state onto that subspace
what Merlin is supposed to send is a lot
of copies of that state intensive
product n over a many so what to do with
them well the referee will he will keep
a random copy that is sort of hopefully
the the thing he will use in the end but
every other copy he will measure with
the observable that consists of the
subspace and its orthogonal complement
now this is a random subspace so the
square projection lens is actually a
over N so if you have n over a copies
you are a thousand n over a copyist
you'llyou'll hope that that other one
copy survive this measurement and get
projected into the subspace so if that
happens then you can test them because
you know what the quantum state looks on
that subspace you have a classical
description of the state on the soft
space so you can do a measurement and if
any of these tests fail you say Merlin
has cheated okay so you do that and it
can be shown that this actually works
even if Merlin sends arbitrary mixed
states so by making mix that he can only
make his life worse if he doesn't send
product States you will only make his
life worse and if he doesn't send the
right state he will not survive the I
mean the would survive the measurement
with the same probability but then these
tests there
they will fail and then you have one
remaining copy and this means that you
can have a protocol for this was a lock
a bits from LS and n over a log n bits
from Berlin for any value a and we can
give use this 2d quantize the
fingerprints and in in in the quantum
fingerprinting protocol with a quant
improver and either quantum and
classical message or both classical
message from Alice and Bob here's an
example just for instance this possible
alesund login qubits Bob sent into the
onesearch bits and Merlin n to the
two-thirds qubits or it is possible that
both Alison Bob's and enter the
one-third bits and Merlin sense into the
titular enter the two-thirds log M
Cubans these things are not possible if
you don't have the proven so that the
product here is much smaller than square
than em right in the psalmist's
modernist curve again but the trade-off
still that that you get em so yeah
conclusion of this I think we have the
simplest proof yet for the quality
problem in simultaneous message passing
by killing correlations and showing that
the encoding I closed the product which
they are not supposed to be because then
you cannot tell apart the distribution
on one inputs from distribution on 0
inputs we have investigated the
non-deterministic versions all
combinations thereof and given tight
bonds up to log factors everywhere and
using these lower bounds we can also
give lower bounds for this task of
untrusted quantum state transform
essentially our protocol here is optimal
ok that's it and thanks for staying
the protocol the root end which sends
like a random row and random follow me
they're also for the same make some
tennis correlation but it's not that
much site for random x because they only
share one out of square hotel
coordinates yeah makes it even more well
I think or a loved one just doesn't
apply because if you condition too much
and in this case if you just take this
photo that actually works the condition
too much then you kill the entropy in
the distribution so let's think